st-pierre 5 heures du matin comme chaque
semaine albert se rend près du marché de
gros de la zac numéro trois pour acheter
des sacs de cacahuètes
il se rend ensuite chez sa maman à bois
d'olives pour préparer les petites
graines en les faisant tourner dans un
bac shooter au feu de bois
albert est ce qu'on appelle à la réunion
un veilleur pistache
sans voir
ce qu'on appelle pistache à la réunion
est en fait le fruit de l'arachide la
cacahuète l'arachide est une plante de
la famille des fabacées ou légumineuses
elle présente la particularité
d'enterrer ses fruits après la
fécondation pour désormais éviter toute
confusion la cacahuète se situe à gauche
et la graine de pistage à droite ce
qu'on appelle donc à la règne pistaches
grillées et en fait de la cacahuète
crise c'est chez sa maman qu'albert gris
ces pistaches il commence très tôt le
matin et c'est la pointe voisins rien
fille jeanne quoi on apprend enfin que
cholet pas bon parce que avec la radiale
le feu à saleilles tout mais là comme le
matin les
et avec humour innu liste les ustensiles
et les ingrédients utiles pour bien
griller les pistaches des 45 le pessac
il faut deux palettes un bac d'eau
étaient faut voir le bas voilà il dit
bien maintenant elle s'embarque plus
rien comme hélas oublie parfois même pas
vécu ça colle pas bien que vivant de son
activité avec la fabrication de la coque
pistaches et des pralines albert déplore
le player de pistaches est un métier en
voie de disparition
marv on avait beaucoup de fun et chaque
ukrainien liquide staff mais maintenant
il ya plus beaucoup dans ces vents de
pareilles c'est un métier en voie de
disparition
à plusieurs moments de la préparation
alvère extraits des graines et légumes
vient et comment soir couleurs
quand la cuisson est à point albert et
sa maman retire le bac du feu ar les
graines en les tournant à foix et
ensuite vide le contenu du bac dans des
caisses
là
en attendant l'arrivée du vendeur mère
et fils nous racontent leur histoire
avec les pistaches avoir grillé pas des
gros bois rond sa palette avec williams
a fait tizi de tizié que qu'ils
appellent à limete dessous des enfants
des ampoules lataniers tous panier c'est
d'animer des dessous négrier négrier
ensemble et nous tu es content et après
il ya les bonnes salles de sous côté
l'église la veine petite boutique appelé
modèle mano des catéchistes et finit
mamaï court et n'a pu y trompez pas
pourriez court et à la volée n'goyi coup
avec ben mes loyers mon grand père a
fait un bon match aussi faisait après
son mari parti vendre
et bien tout ça là à l'arrêt de la tête
et après un moment donné comment elle
travaille ma musulmans coma comme un
écho négrier aussi a déjà fait ça avant
et ben pourquoi pas même si rappaz ben
il fait que a fait comme ça fait mes
yeux mais quand tu as un peu plus tard
dans la matinée
c'est l'arrivée du vendeur jean-luc
vient acheter les pistaches grillées
avec albert dohmen nippon piste assez
gagné mais n'a trouvé cinq d'être un
petit corner partenaires clients
attendent à moi comme il sonne comme la
piñata - peut-être un petit corner me
prépare parce que longtemps qu'on y
arrive pistache moi pourquoi décoller
concert client final rive est fini pour
en acheter mais comme la fourmi masse
avait fourbi massa mais qu'il faut
savoir que lyon petit comme avant la
piste a appuyé le saint pierrois
sillonnent ensuite les quartiers pour
chercher des clients comme albert il
exerce ce métier depuis plus de vingt
ans un métier que tous deux sont en
peine de voir disparaître mais aimerait
que cette tradition là il continue parce
que veut dire à coeur parce que
il faut regarder nos traditions ce
groupe est là
i l usage